pas trois si vous regardez la télévision
justement peut-être allez-vous bientôt
cliquez plutôt que de zapper de
nombreuses télévisions se sont installés
sur internet
mais les débuts sont plutôt difficiles
certaines d'entre elles ont même déjà
disparu des écrans lors de la lex benoît
vers ans on avait débarqué dans
l'univers des webtv pionniers de
l'espace virtuel streaming numérique
bonne modèle de référence
ce requiem que françois et antoine
compose avec des images d'archivés
c'est celui de leur télévision une
clique vision est ce que ça allait non
ça n'a pas tenu et laventure commencé il
ya deux ans s'est brutalement arrêté 25
des 30 permanente été licenciés la cause
des investisseurs après avoir risqué 17
millions de francs ont refusé d'aller
plus loin on peut pas s'abstraire de du
contexte général qui concerne l'ensemble
des nouvelles technologies de
l'information dans le monde
les difficultés que connaissent
aujourd'hui le secteur de l'internet
problème de modèle économique de
confiance des investisseurs du fait
qu'ils ont été trop loin dans un sens
c'est bon à celle balancier dans l'autre
sens et ce contexte économique
n'explique pas tout si des écrans noirs
ou des mires de télévision ont remplacé
certaines chaînes
c'est aussi parce que leur accès limité
en effet seuls 9% des français possèdent
une ligne haut débit une technologie
indispensable pour recevoir correctement
la télé sur son pc pour les
investisseurs qui ont cru au web qui vit
comme le groupe de presse et map ces
startups sont apparus trop tôt son
apport du haut débit en une fenêtre fait
3 cm sur 4 et faut être honnête que
regarder un petit clip vidéo avec 3 4 5
images par seconde en centimètres sur
cannes c'est quand même pas terrible
donc temps que le déni sera pas
démocratisé je pense pas que les web
télés vont pouvoir rencontrer le leur
audience en face à leurs difficultés
financières pour subsister
les télés du web ont dû apprendre à se
diversifier en plus de leur programme
elles vendent désormais des prestations
vidéo à des entreprises ici par exemple
à canal web
la pionnière des webtv 80% du chiffre
d'affaires provient de ce commerce
ça met du temps à s'installer aux médias
donc dans le secteur où nous sommes
c'est la télévision numérique il faut
pas s'attendre à des rentabilités au
bout d'un an ou deux alors pendant qu'on
développe sur plusieurs plusieurs années
le modèle télévision numérique grand
public la force en laye pour pas se
priver d'une chance de revue reste la
question de la qualité des programmes
si ceci laisse parfois à désirer il
constitue un fabuleux creuset de
créativité qui rappelle les débuts des
radios libres dans les années 80 dans un
instant le rappel de tous